[applause]
about the first explosion, I didn’t understand right away, I
heard the
gurk of my door,
I quickly ran my brother screaming, wake up the
children, I quickly jumped up the children, started
waking them up on one bed, covered them as much as we
could, but
rushed out of the door as much as possible, completely
tore the door completely and into
back inward I remember when we
woke up Well, I heard some
sounds there, as if something was right in my ear
and as if now a person is a
terrible mother
for me and I
looked
at the Russian Federation behind my brothers sister in general how she
does it all a
special operation
I don’t think  that this is some kind of special operation
And what how
to convey it
Well, what is all this called, it’s definitely not
sleepy
[applause]